The following was recorded from inside an ice plunge Okay, all right When a core's life is cold enough the mountains on the can turn blue So the next time you want to cold loggered cold filtered cold package Core's light just wait until those glorious mountains on the can turn blue. Whoo, it's easy to say that fast when you're freezing gold. Spring is here and you can now get almost anything you need
The following was recorded from inside an ice plunge Okay, all right When a core's life is cold enough the mountains on the can turn blue So the next time you want to cold loggered cold filtered cold package Core's light just wait until those glorious mountains on the can turn blue. Whoo, it's easy to say that fast when you're freezing gold. Spring is here and you can now get almost anything you need|||以下内容录制于冰浴内部。好的，行。当雪花酷速（Coors Light）足够冰时，罐子上的山脉就会变成蓝色。所以，下次你想喝冷酿、冷过滤、冷包装的雪花酷速时，只需等到罐子上那些壮丽的山脉变成蓝色。呜，当你冻得发抖时，要说得这么快可真容易。春天来了，你现在几乎可以买到任何你需要的东西
delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now.
delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now.|||通过 Uber Eats 配送。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？你无法买到修剪好的草坪配送上门，但你可以买到帕尔马鸡肉配送上门。阳光？不行。一些酒？可以。通过 Uber Eats 几乎、几乎可以配送任何东西。立即订购。
Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See after details. Hello everyone. Hi there. Welcome to a little Friday chit chat. We were not expecting to do a Friday chit chat today, but Angela, as you and I were coming into the building, we solved a major Friday chit chat mystery.
Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See after details. Hello everyone. Hi there. Welcome to a little Friday chit chat. We were not expecting to do a Friday chit chat today, but Angela, as you and I were coming into the building, we solved a major Friday chit chat mystery.|||酒类仅限部分市场供应。详情请查看应用。立即订购。部分市场供应酒类。详情见后。大家好。你们好。欢迎来到简短的周五闲聊。我们今天本来没打算做周五闲聊的，但是安吉拉，当我和你走进大楼时，我们解开了一个重大的周五闲聊谜团。
Well, here's what happened, you guys. We arrived at the same time and we got into the elevator. There was one other lady in it. She had hit floor number eight and Jenna, like I look and our floor is not lit up. So I'm like, did you hit the button? And she turns to me and goes, no, I hit floor number two. And I said, what? I said, I want to see this man in the low chair. And I said, he's probably not there. It was probably like an anomaly. Like, what are the odds? But we got off on the second floor and we turned.
Well, here's what happened, you guys. We arrived at the same time and we got into the elevator. There was one other lady in it. She had hit floor number eight and Jenna, like I look and our floor is not lit up. So I'm like, did you hit the button? And she turns to me and goes, no, I hit floor number two. And I said, what? I said, I want to see this man in the low chair. And I said, he's probably not there. It was probably like an anomaly. Like, what are the odds? But we got off on the second floor and we turned.|||事情是这样的，各位。我们同时到达并上了电梯。里面还有另一位女士。她按了八楼，然后詹娜，我一看我们的楼层没有亮。于是我说：“你按按钮了吗？”她转过身对我说：“没有，我按了二楼。”我说：“什么？”我说：“我想看看这个坐在低矮椅子上的男人。”我说：“他可能不在那里。这可能只是个特例。就像，几率有多大？”但我们在二楼下了电梯，然后拐了弯。
And I did this. Because guess what? Man in low chair was there. But I was like, and is this the man in the low chair you were talking about? Because this is not how I imagined it. And I said, it wasn't low enough for you? It was just, tell me you guys, Sam Cassie,
And I did this. Because guess what? Man in low chair was there. But I was like, and is this the man in the low chair you were talking about? Because this is not how I imagined it. And I said, it wasn't low enough for you? It was just, tell me you guys, Sam Cassie,|||然后我做了这个动作。因为你们猜怎么着？那个坐在低矮椅子上的男人就在那儿。但当时我想：“这就是你说的那个坐在低矮椅子上的男人吗？”因为这和我想象的完全不一样。我说：“这还不够低吗？这只是，你们告诉我，萨姆、卡西，”
when Angela told the story, did you imagine that there was a, like a business man doing business at his like businessy desk in a super low chair? I think I pictured who ran Potterstown in It's a Wonderful Life. I don't know. The old man, the evil old man.
when Angela told the story, did you imagine that there was a, like a business man doing business at his like businessy desk in a super low chair? I think I pictured who ran Potterstown in It's a Wonderful Life. I don't know. The old man, the evil old man.|||当安吉拉讲这个故事时，你们有没有想象过，有一个类似商人的家伙，坐在一个超级矮的椅子上，在他那种商务办公桌前谈生意？我想象的是《生活多美好》里经营波特斯敦的那个人。我不知道。那个老头，那个邪恶的老头。
I just pictured him, but like two feet lower in his chair. Okay. Cassie? I just think this building is full of like artists and weirdos that I think it could be anything. Okay. Thank you, you guys. See, there's several interpretations. I like this. And here's the thing.
I just pictured him, but like two feet lower in his chair. Okay. Cassie? I just think this building is full of like artists and weirdos that I think it could be anything. Okay. Thank you, you guys. See, there's several interpretations. I like this. And here's the thing.|||我只是想象他坐在椅子上，但比正常位置低了两英尺左右。好吧。卡西？我只是觉得这栋楼里到处都是艺术家和怪人，我觉得什么情况都有可能发生。好吧。谢谢你们。看，有几种不同的解释。我喜欢这样。事情是这样的。
Jenna said, is that the same man? And I said, no, it's several interpretations. I like this. And here's the thing. Jenna said, is that the same man? And I said, no, it's not. It's a new man in a low chair. But there's also a lady outside this time in a low chair in the hallway who looked right at me when I went, oh, like. Also, I, okay, go on, go on. Now.
Jenna said, is that the same man? And I said, no, it's several interpretations. I like this. And here's the thing. Jenna said, is that the same man? And I said, no, it's not. It's a new man in a low chair. But there's also a lady outside this time in a low chair in the hallway who looked right at me when I went, oh, like. Also, I, okay, go on, go on. Now.|||詹那是同一个人吗？我说，不，有几种不同的解释。我喜欢这样。事情是这样的。詹娜说：“那是同一个人吗？”我说：“不，不是。这是一个坐在低椅子上的新男人。”但这次大厅外面还有一个坐在低椅子上的女士，当我发出“噢”的声音时，她直直地看着我。还有，我，好吧，接着说，接着说。现在。
That's as far as I got. Listen, that day when I came in, I was, go on. Now that's as far as I got. Listen, that day when I came in, I was in a rush. Yeah. You got off at the wrong floor, accidentally saw a man in a low chair, got back on the elevator. Exactly. I didn't take a lot of time to look.
That's as far as I got. Listen, that day when I coming in, I was, go on. Now that's as far as I got. Listen, that day when I came in, I was in a rush. Yeah. You got off at the wrong floor, accidentally saw a man in a low chair, got back on the elevator. Exactly. I didn't take a lot of time to look.|||我就说到这儿。听着，那天我进来的时候，我，接着说。现在我就说到这儿。听着，那天我进来的时候，我赶时间。对。你在错误的楼层下了电梯，意外地看到一个坐在低矮椅子上的男人，然后又回到了电梯里。没错。我没有花太多时间去看。
Okay, well, it was just, it was just a waiting room for a dental office and people were just in chairs and they weren't particularly low. Lower than you would expect though. Were they though? They seemed like regular chairs. I mean they just seem like people sitting in chairs waiting for their dental work.
Okay, well, it was just, it was just a waiting room for a dental office and people were just in chairs and they weren't particularly low. Lower than you would expect though. Were they though? They seemed like regular chairs. I mean they just seem like people sitting in chairs waiting for their dental work.|||好吧，那其实，那只是牙科诊所的候诊室，人们只是坐在椅子上，而且椅子也不是特别低。不过比你想象的要低。是吗？它们看起来像普通的椅子。我的意思是，它们看起来就像人们坐在椅子上等待看牙医一样。
If you've never seen a door open in this whole building the whole time we've been here and you get off the elevator thinking you're on your floor and there's a door open and a man in a little chair. You keep saying little chair, but it's a regular chair. Here's the thing, the guy I saw, the original guy, was very tall. So put him in that chair with his long legs. Okay, fair enough. Anyway, guys, it's a dentist office.
If you've never seen a door open in this whole building the whole time we've been here and you get off the elevator thinking you're on your floor and there's a door open and a man in a little chair. You keep saying little chair, but it's a regular chair. Here's the thing, the guy I saw, the original guy, was very tall. So put him in that chair with his long legs. Okay, fair enough. Anyway, guys, it's a dentist office.|||如果你在我们来这里的整个时间里，从来没见过这栋楼里的哪扇门打开过，而你以为自己到了所在的楼层就出了电梯，结果发现一扇门开着，里面有个男人坐在一把小椅子上。你一直说小椅子，但那是一把普通的椅子。事情是这样的，我看到的那个家伙，最初那个家伙，非常高。所以把他那长腿塞进那把椅子里。好吧，有道理。不管怎样，各位，那是个牙科诊所。
If you need to get your teeth cleaned, there's one on the second floor. Okay. Um, we have more news. Another update. We won the Webby y'all. Yes, we did. Thank you to everybody. Yes.
If you need to get your teeth cleaned, there's one on the second floor. Okay. Um, we have more news. Another update. We won the Webby y'all. Yes, we did. Thank you to everybody. Yes.|||如果你需要洗牙，二楼就有一家。好吧。嗯，我们还有更多消息。另一个更新。我们获得威比奖了，伙计们。是的，我们做到了。谢谢大家。是的。
Thank you so much for voting. We won the 2025 People's Voice Award for Best Comedy Podcast. Come on. Thank you so much to everyone for voting. You know, it felt so special to me. We won when the show first came out. And now to win again after all these years, we all worked so hard on the show.
Thank you so much for voting. We won the 2025 People's Voice Award for Best Comedy Podcast. Come on. Thank you so much to everyone for voting. You know, it felt so special to me. We won when the show first came out. And now to win again after all these years, we all worked so hard on the show.|||非常感谢大家的投票。我们赢得了 2025 年人民之声奖最佳喜剧播客。太棒了。非常感谢所有投票的人。你知道，这对我来说感觉太特别了。节目刚出的时候我们得过奖。现在时隔多年又再次获奖，我们为这个节目付出了太多的努力。
And I was so moved by it. I was really moved by it. I sort of announced it to my family. I was like, we won a Webby. And they were like, oh my gosh. Well, the thing I love about it is I think it's the coolest looking of the awards. It looks like a spring. It's like a spindle like a spiral, spirally thing. It's very visually interesting. I know. I love it. Now we have two. Yay. I have another chit chat topic that I was excited to bring to the group. Okay.
And I was so moved by it. I was really moved by it. I sort of announced it to my family. I was like, we won a Webby. And they were like, oh my gosh. Well, the thing I love about it is I think it's the coolest looking of the awards. It looks like a spring. It's like a spindle like a spiral, spirally thing. It's very visually interesting. I know. I love it. Now we have two. Yay. I have another chit chat topic that I was excited to bring to the group. Okay.|||我对此非常感动。我真的很感动。我算是向我的家人宣布了这个消息。我说：“我们获得威比奖了。”他们就说：“噢，天哪。”嗯，我最喜欢它的一点是，我觉得它是所有奖项里外观最酷的。它看起来像一个弹簧。就像一个纺锤，一个螺旋形的东西。它在视觉上非常有趣。我知道。我很喜欢。现在我们有两个了。耶。我有另一个闲聊话题，我很高兴把它带给大家。好吧。
I want to talk about a skincare product that I'm really enthusiastic about. Okay. Go on. Yeah, you have us. It is inexpensive. You can buy it at the drug store and it's Aquaphor. Okay. I love Aquaphor. Yeah, Aquaphor is great.
I want to talk about a skincare product that I'm really enthusiastic about. Okay. Go on. Yeah, you have us. It is inexpensive. You can buy it at the drug store and it's Aquaphor. Okay. I love Aquaphor. Yeah, Aquaphor is great.|||我想聊聊一款我非常热衷的护肤品。好吧。接着说。是的，我们在听。它很便宜。你可以在药店买到它，它就是 Aquaphor（优色林万用修护膏）。好吧。我很喜欢 Aquaphor。是的，Aquaphor 太棒了。
You said you love Aquaphor, Sam. Tell me more. I use it on all my tattoos afterwards. Yeah. It's great. What does it do? It's like a barrier. It's greasy.
You said you love Aquaphor, Sam. Tell me more. I use it on all my tattoos afterwards. Yeah. It's great. What does it do? It's like a barrier. It's greasy.|||你说你喜欢 Aquaphor，萨姆。多跟我讲讲。我所有的纹身之后都用它。是的。它太棒了。它有什么用？它就像一个屏障。它很油腻。
It's like Vaseline. It's a petroleum jelly. And it's great for sunburns. Okay, that's where I think I've heard it. Yes, and it holds moisture in and creates a barrier, but I started using it when I was doing radiation and my doctor said I should slather myself in aquaphor and sleep in it.
It's like Vaseline. It's a petroleum jelly. And it's great for sunburns. Okay, that's where I think I've heard it. Yes, and it holds moisture in and creates a barrier, but I started using it when I was doing radiation and my doctor said I should slather myself in aquaphor and sleep in it.|||它就像凡士林。它是一种凡士林软膏。它对晒伤非常有效。好吧，我想我就是在那里听说过它的。是的，它能锁住水分并形成屏障，但我开始使用它是在我接受放射治疗的时候，我的医生说我应该在身上涂满 aquaphor 然后带着它睡觉。
She's like, it's hard to wear during the day because it's kind of greasy. But I was like, amazing. My daughter got a sunburn, we threw some aquaphor on it. I was like, hey, radiation lady said this is the best thing for burns. Put it on her. But then, not to go too deep into my medical side effects,
She's like, it's hard to wear during the day because it's kind of greasy. But I was like, amazing. My daughter got a sunburn, we threw some aquaphor on it. I was like, hey, radiation lady said this is the best thing for burns. Put it on her. But then, not to go too deep into my medical side effects,|||她说，白天很难涂，因为它有点油腻。但我当时想，太神奇了。我女儿晒伤了，我们在上面抹了点 aquaphor。我说：“嘿，那个做放疗的医生说这是治疗烧伤最好的东西。给她抹上。”但是接着，虽然不想深入谈论我的医疗副作用，
but at one point, I got this really bad rash. Remember, lady? All over my neck. All over your neck. And all over, kind of up encroaching on my face. I do. And the dermatologist said, put some aquaphor on it. So I started slathering my face and chest and neck and aquaphor. And then when the rash went away, I got gifted like a fancy schmancy
but at one point, I got this really bad rash. Remember, lady? All over my neck. All over your neck. And all over, kind of up encroaching on my face. I do. And the dermatologist said, put some aquaphor on it. So I started slathering my face and chest and neck and aquaphor. And then when the rash went away, I got gifted like a fancy schmancy|||但有一次，我得了非常严重的皮疹。记得吗，女士？我整个脖子上都是。你整个脖子上都是。而且到处都是，有点蔓延到我的脸上了。我记得。皮肤科医生说，抹点 aquaphor。于是我开始在脸上、胸部和脖子上厚厚地涂上 aquaphor。然后当皮疹消失后，我收到了一份像模像样的礼物——
face cream. And guess what happened? Rash. Thank you, Cassie. I broke out into a rash again. And then I started using the aquaphor again. And then blah, blah, blah. I had to have my makeup professionally done. And the makeup artist was like, what skincare do you use? Your skin is luscious. Your skin is beautiful. It's never been this beautiful.
face cream. And guess what happened? Rash. Thank you, Cassie. I broke out into a rash again. And then I started using the aquaphor again. And then blah, blah, blah. I had to have my makeup professionally done. And the makeup artist was like, what skincare do you use? Your skin is luscious. Your skin is beautiful. It's never been this beautiful.|||面霜。你猜怎么着？皮疹又犯了。谢谢你，卡西。我又起了一身皮疹。然后我又开始使用 aquaphor。接着巴拉巴拉。我不得不找专业人士化装。化妆师问：“你用什么护肤品？你的皮肤太水润了。你的皮肤太美了。从来没有这么美过。”
And she's known me for years. And I said, aqua four. So there it is. I'm putting it out in the world. You don't need fancy schmancy. Don't pass aqua four up. Don't sleep in the aqua four. Now with the sleeping,
And she's known me for years. And I said, aqua four. So there it is. I'm putting it out in the world. You don't need fancy schmancy. Don't pass aqua four up. Don't sleep in the aqua four. Now with the sleeping,|||她认识我好几年了。我说：“是 aquaphor。”所以就是这样。我把它公之于众。你不需要那些花里胡哨的东西。不要错过 aquaphor。别带着 aquaphor 睡觉。说到睡觉，
do you get in like an aqua four sleeping bag? No. Brim, we will picture you so tight in the top. So Lee doesn't get covered in grease. No, I put it on like about an hour before I go to bed. So it's not as like potent. Like, I love the visual though, because it's like, you know, like how your grandma used to sleep
do you get in like an aqua four sleeping bag? No. Brim, we will picture you so tight in the top. So Lee doesn't get covered in grease. No, I put it on like about an hour before I go to bed. So it's not as like potent. Like, I love the visual though, because it's like, you know, like how your grandma used to sleep|||你会钻进类似 aquaphor 睡袋的东西里吗？不。布林，我们会想象你紧紧地裹在顶部。这样李就不会沾满油脂了。不，我大概在睡前一个小时左右涂上它。所以它没有那么浓烈。不过，我很喜欢这个画面，因为就像，你知道的，就像你奶奶以前睡觉时那样——
in gloves with lotion. I love the idea that you have a special sleeping sack for when you are up. So soft. Yes. Now listen, I'm not a skin expert, believe it or not. You're not? I'm not.
in gloves with lotion. I love the idea that you have a special sleeping sack for when you are up. So soft. Yes. Now listen, I'm not a skin expert, believe it or not. You're not? I'm not.|||戴着涂满乳液的手套。我喜欢这个想法，你竟然有一个专门的睡眠袋，当你醒着的时候用。太柔软了。是的。现在听着，信不信由你，我不是皮肤专家。你不是？我不是。
I'm also not a dermatologist. I thought that was the extra degree you did. No, I never finished it. Oh, OK. Not an anesthetician, but so there could be a thing where I run dry in general. My skin runs dry, it's always parched. I drink a ton of water.
I'm also not a dermatologist. I thought that was the extra degree you did. No, I never finished it. Oh, OK. Not an anesthetician, but so there could be a thing where I run dry in general. My skin runs dry, it's always parched. I drink a ton of water.|||我也不是皮肤科医生。我以为那是你额外修得的学位呢。不，我从来没读完。哦，好吧。也不是美容师，所以可能存在这样一种情况，我总的来说比较容易干燥。我的皮肤很干，总是缺水。我喝了成吨的水。
My skin is always so thirsty. So if you have like an oily skin or you're prone to breakouts, maybe don't take my aquifer advice or ask a professional, but I really love it. It's probably good in dry climates too. Like we live in a dry climate. We do.
My skin is always so thirsty. So if you have like an oily skin or you're prone to breakouts, maybe don't take my aquifer advice or ask a professional, but I really love it. It's probably good in dry climates too. Like we live in a dry climate. We do.|||我的皮肤总是那么渴望水分。所以如果你是油性皮肤或者容易长痘，也许不要听取我对 aquaphor 的建议，或者去问专业人士，但我真的很喜欢它。它可能也很适合干燥的气候。就像我们生活在干燥的气候中。我们确实是。
That's a good point. Yeah. Yeah. This might be a whole different conversation if you lived like in Scotland. Or Florida. Oh. Florida is very moist.
That's a good point. Yeah. Yeah. This might be a whole different conversation if you lived like in Scotland. Or Florida. Oh. Florida is very moist.|||说得好。对。是的。如果你住在苏格兰之类的地方，这可能是完全不同的对话。或者佛罗里达。哦。佛罗里达非常潮湿。
Muggy. Muggy. Right? Yeah. Well, I have a hot travel tip for everybody. Yeah. Ready? Yeah. Should you find yourself in the Phoenix Airport in the Southwest Terminal? Okay. There's a display of all of these handmade quil around taking pictures of quilts and reading the little plaques. And it's so beautiful. I thought, how wonderful, how nice.
Muggy. Muggy. Right? Yeah. Well, I have a hot travel tip for everybody. Yeah. Ready? Yeah. Should you find yourself in the Phoenix Airport in the Southwest Terminal? Okay. There's a display of all of these handmade quil around taking pictures of quilts and reading the little plaques. And it's so beautiful. I thought, how wonderful, how nice.|||闷热。闷热。对吧？是的。嗯，我有一个热门的旅行小贴士要分享给大家。对。准备好了吗？对。如果你发现自己身处菲尼克斯机场的西南航站楼？好吧。那里有一个展览，展示了所有这些手工拼布被子，周围有人在给被子拍照并阅读小牌匾。它是如此美丽。我想，多棒啊，多好啊。
You guys are looking at me kind of blank. It's snow, it's really sweet. I was waiting for the point of the story to kick in. That's it, Sam. It's an appreciation of art at the Southwest Terminal in Phoenix. Yeah, my thought was, this is just very on brand for Angela. Yeah.
You guys are looking at me kind of blank. It's snow, it's really sweet. I was waiting for the point of the story to kick in. That's it, Sam. It's an appreciation of art at the Southwest Terminal in Phoenix. Yeah, my thought was, this is just very on brand for Angela. Yeah.|||你们看着我的眼神有点茫然。这很纯粹，真的很温馨。我在等这个故事的重点出现呢。就是这样，萨姆。这是对菲尼克斯西南航站楼艺术的欣赏。是的，我的想法是，这非常符合安吉拉的风格。对。
If I was to run into you in the wild, it would be looking at quilts. Well, I took all the pictures, I took pictures of all of them. Yeah, I wouldn't be surprised if you missed your following three connected nights. You know, the funny thing is there was a family, like clearly they're on a big family trip.
If I was to run into you in the wild, it would be looking at quilts. Well, I took all the pictures, I took pictures of all of them. Yeah, I wouldn't be surprised if you missed your following three connected nights. You know, the funny thing is there was a family, like clearly they're on a big family trip.|||如果我在野外偶遇你，你肯定在看被子。好吧，我拍了所有的照片，我把它们全都拍下来了。对，如果你错过接下来的三个转机航班，我也不会感到惊讶。你知道，有趣的是有一家人，很显然他们是一起进行一次盛大的家庭旅行。
I imagined it was like a big family reunion or for a wedding. There was multiple generations of age and they were taking a huge group photo like, we're on our way. But they were right in front of one of the quotes I wanted to take a picture of. So I sort of scooched behind them to get my picture and then I saw them, they looked over their shoulder like what the f**k this lady weren't you clearly trying to take a group picture and she's like behind us reading the quilt plaque and I turned I was like oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry but anyway um there you go little hot tip for you. I love that hot tip um if you were a travel blogger that would be
I imagined it was like a big family reunion or for a wedding. There was multiple generations of age and they were taking a huge group photo like, we're on our way. But they were right in front of one of the quotes I wanted to take a picture of. So I sort of scooched behind them to get my picture and then I saw them, they looked over their shoulder like what the f**k this lady weren't you clearly trying to take a picture and she's like behind us reading the quilt plaque and I turned I was like oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry but anyway um there you go little hot tip for you. I love that hot tip um if you were a travel blogger that would be|||我猜那就像是一次盛大的家庭聚会有或者为了参加婚礼。有好几代人，他们正在拍一张宏大的合影，好像在说“我们正在路上”。但他们正好挡在了我想拍照的一幅拼布被子前面。所以我有点挪到他们身后去拍照，然后我看到他们转过头来，那眼神好像在说“他妈的这女的是谁，你不是明显想拍照吗，而她却在我们身后读被子的牌匾”。我转过身去说：“哦，对不起，对不起，对不起。”不过不管怎样，嗯，这就是给你们的小贴士。我很喜欢这个热门小贴士，嗯，如果你是个旅游博主，那会是
a very unique travel tip. Thank you. There are a lot of airports that have lovely art features that really help pass the time. Yeah. And then there's the Denver Airport, which is like conspiracy town. What? What's happening at the Denver Airport? I mean, I'm in that airport all the time.
a very unique travel tip. Thank you. There are a lot of airports that have lovely art features that really help pass the time. Yeah. And then there's the Denver Airport, which is like conspiracy town. What? What's happening at the Denver Airport? I mean, I'm in that airport all the time.|||一个非常独特的旅游贴士。谢谢。有很多机场都有可爱的艺术特色，真的很能打发时间。对。然后就是丹佛机场，那里简直就像是阴谋之城。什么？丹佛机场怎么了？我的意思是，我经常去那个机场。
Supposedly built by a bunch of Freemasons if I'm telling the story, right and it's supposedly there's like a bunch of hidden Messages written all over in it. The artwork is really strange in there Yeah, and then they're outside of the airport is like this horse statue. Yes to get it There is like such a long Weird tragic story to get the horse statue the such a long, weird, tragic story. To get the horse statue, the big blue one? Yeah, and it's really scary. It looks like a horse that's like...
Supposedly built by a bunch of Freemasons if I'm telling the story, right and it's supposedly there's like a bunch of hidden Messages written all over in it. The artwork is really strange in there Yeah, and then they're outside of the airport is like this horse statue. Yes to get it There is like such a long Weird tragic story to get the horse statue the such a long, weird, tragic story. To get the horse statue, the big blue one? Yeah, and it's really scary. It looks like a horse that's like...|||如果我没记错的话，据说它是被一群共济会员建造的，而且据说里面到处都写满了各种隐藏的信息。那里的艺术品真的很奇怪。是的，然后机场外面还有这个马雕像。是的，为了弄到它——弄到那座马雕像，有一个如此漫长、诡异又悲惨的故事，一个如此漫长、诡异又悲惨的故事。为了弄到那个马雕像，那个巨大的蓝色雕像？是的，而且它真的很吓人。它看起来像一匹马，就像……
Well, yeah, scary. Yeah. You know, listeners want to Google deep dive it. It's the Denver airport. It's just very strange. I'm literally there all the time because Josh's family. I'll have to look it up. Should we go there and like mom detective it? Yes. And see what the hidden messages are? We'll also need to visit Josh's family
Well, yeah, scary. Yeah. You know, listeners want to Google deep dive it. It's the Denver airport. It's just very strange. I'm literally there all the time because Josh's family. I'll have to look it up. Should we go there and like mom detective it? Yes. And see what the hidden messages are? We'll also need to visit Josh's family|||嗯，是的，很吓人。是的。你知道，听众们如果想在谷歌上深入了解一下的话。这就是丹佛机场。它只是非常奇怪。我真的经常去那里，因为乔许的家人。我得去查查。我们应该去那里像妈妈侦探一样调查一番吗？是的。看看里面有什么隐藏的信息吗？我们还需要顺便拜访乔许的家人
because we'll have to make an extended stay. That's fine. OK. Google search says, the Denver International Airport conspiracy theories revolve around the idea that the airport is somehow a hub for sinister activities, including secret government plans, new world order agendas, theories revolve around the idea that the airport is somehow a hub for sinister activities, including secret government plans, new world order agendas, or even alien involvement.
because we'll have to make an extended stay. That's fine. OK. Google search says, the Denver International Airport conspiracy theories revolve around the idea that the airport is somehow a hub for sinister activities, including secret government plans, new world order agendas, theories revolve around the idea that the airport is somehow a hub for sinister activities, including secret government plans, new world order agendas, or even alien involvement.|||因为我们得延长逗留时间。没问题。好的。谷歌搜索显示，丹佛国际机场的阴谋论围绕着这样一个观点：该机场不知何故是邪恶活动的枢纽，包括秘密政府计划、新世界秩序议程，阴谋论围绕着这样一个观点：该机场不知何故是邪恶活动的枢纽，包括秘密政府计划、新世界秩序议程，甚至有外星人参与。
Oh my goodness. You know what I've always thought of the Denver Airport? What? Now this might go to my love of chocolate meringue pie, but I just, we call it the pie airport because it looks like the top, it looks like chocolate meringue. Ooh. Oh. So that was my take on the Denver Airport. Wow. I've got to do some Googling now.
Oh my goodness. You know what I've always thought of the Denver Airport? What? Now this might go to my love of chocolate meringue pie, but I just, we call it the pie airport because it looks like the top, it looks like chocolate meringue. Ooh. Oh. So that was my take on the Denver Airport. Wow. I've got to do some Googling now.|||噢，天哪。你知道我一直对丹佛机场有什么看法吗？什么？这可能扯到我对巧克力蛋白甜饼的热爱，但我只是，我们叫它派机场，因为它看起来像顶部，看起来像巧克力蛋白甜饼。噢。哦。这就是我对丹佛机场的看法。哇。我现在得去谷歌一下了。
I wonder if Josh's family's ever heard about this. Maybe. It seems like it would have come up in conversation once over all these years. I got stranded at the Denver Airport once with my two kids and I found everyone in the airport to be really nice For what it's worth. Yeah, I mean I've had no issues Well, I'm intrigued Before we wrap up Friday chit chat, I do feel like we need to say happy birthday today's Cassie's birthday We will have treats and fun later Today's Cassie's birthday! Yes, happy birthday Cassie. Happy birthday! Thank you everyone.
I wonder if Josh's family's ever heard about this. Maybe. It seems like it would have come up in conversation once over all these years. I got stranded at the Denver Airport once with my two kids and I found everyone in the airport to be really nice For what it's worth. Yeah, I mean I've had no issues Well, I'm intrigued Before we wrap up Friday chit chat, I do feel like we need to say happy birthday today's Cassie's birthday We will have treats and fun later Today's Cassie's birthday! Yes, happy birthday Cassie. Happy birthday! Thank you everyone.|||我不知道乔许的家人是否听说过这个。也许吧。这么多年来，这似乎应该在谈话中被提及过一次。我有一次带着两个孩子被困在丹佛机场，我发现机场里的每个人都非常友好，不管怎么说。是的，我的意思是我的确没遇到什么问题。好吧，我很感兴趣。在我们结束周五闲聊之前，我觉得我们必须说一声生日快乐，今天是卡西的生日。我们待会儿会有好吃的和好玩的。今天是卡西的生日！是的，生日快乐，卡西。生日快乐！谢谢大家。
We will have treats and fun later. And I also want to give a shout out to my parents who came in the studio and helped us open up and organize fan mail. They helped us put up stuff. Finally, my dad hung up our special plaque award thing from Spotify that we got for our 100 million Spotify downloads.
We will have treats and fun later. And I also want to give a shout out to my parents who came in the studio and helped us open up and organize fan mail. They helped us put up stuff. Finally, my dad hung up our special plaque award thing from Spotify that we got for our 100 million Spotify downloads.|||我们待会儿会有好吃的和好玩的。我还想特别感谢我的父母，他们来到录音室帮我们拆开并整理粉丝来信。他们帮我们布置东西。最后，我爸爸挂上了我们从 Spotify 获得的特殊牌匾奖励，那是为了表彰我们的 Spotify 下载量达到 1 亿次。
Yes, we didn't know how to hang it because it's a concrete wall. But your dad had all the tools and I walked in and he was on a ladder. It was amazing. And then we also, I finally got to hang up Sam's gift of us with Keanu. Yes.
Yes, we didn't know how to hang it because it's a concrete wall. But your dad had all the tools and I walked in and he was on a ladder. It's amazing. And then we also, I finally got to hang up Sam's gift of us with Keanu. Yes.|||是的，我们不知道怎么挂，因为那是混凝土墙。但你爸爸准备了所有的工具，我走进去时他正站在梯子上。太棒了。然后我们还，我终于把萨姆送给我们的基努合影挂上去了。是的。
So now that is above my desk. But yeah, so we got all decorating done and thank you to my folks for coming in. Yeah. All right. Well, do you guys have any additional chatty? We good. Cassie, what are you doing for your birthday? I'm playing pickup basketball with a bunch of my friends.
So now that is above my desk. But yeah, so we got all decorating done and thank you to my folks for coming in. Yeah. All right. Well, do you guys have any additional chatty? We good. Cassie, what are you doing for your birthday? I'm playing pickup basketball with a bunch of my friends.|||所以现在那张照片就在我办公桌上方。但是，是的，我们把所有的装饰都弄好了，谢谢我的父母过来帮忙。对。好吧。那么，各位还有什么要聊的吗？我们很好。卡西，你生日打算怎么过？我和一群朋友去打野球。
So fun. And then right now, the NBA is in playoffs, and my partner and I are Clippers fans. So they're playing tonight, and we're going to group for them. So fun. Yeah, just a lot of basketball and office ladies, which I can't complain. Sam, you had your birthday one week ago. I did, yeah.
So fun. And then right now, the NBA is in playoffs, and my partner and I are Clippers fans. So they're playing tonight, and we're going to group for them. So fun. Yeah, just a lot of basketball and office ladies, which I can't complain. Sam, you had your birthday one week ago. I did, yeah.|||太有趣了。然后现在，NBA 正在进行季后赛，我和伴侣都是快船队的球迷。所以他们今晚有比赛，我们要去给他们加油。太有趣了。是的，就是有很多篮球和办公室女士们的节目，这让我无可挑剔。萨姆，你一周前刚过完生日。是的，我过过了。
Which we celebrated. Thank you. Did you end up going to that Italian restaurant that Lee used to be a waiter at? Pergoletta, yes I did on Hillhurst Avenue in California. Yeah I did. It's my favorite restaurant in Los Angeles. It's so good. I've never been. I want to go. It's great. I'll take you. Yay! All right. Well there's some office ladies chit chat for you guys. We hope you have a great Friday. And we'll see you next week. Bye. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Which we celebrated. Thank you. Did you end up going to that Italian restaurant that Lee used to be a waiter at? Pergoletta, yes I did on Hillhurst Avenue in California. Yeah I did. It's my favorite restaurant in Los Angeles. It's so good. I've never been. I want to go. It's great. I'll take you. Yay! All right. Well there's some office ladies chit chat for you guys. We hope you have a great Friday. And we'll see you next week. Bye. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.|||我们庆祝过了。谢谢。你最后去了李以前当过服务生的那家意大利餐厅吗？Pergoletta，是的，我去了，在加利福尼亚的希尔赫斯特大道上。是的，我去了。这是我在洛杉矶最喜欢的餐厅。太好吃了。我没去过。我想去。很棒的。我带你去。耶！好吧。这就是给你们准备的一些办公室女士的闲聊。希望你们周五过得愉快。我们下周见。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 出品的一档节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Odyssey 的执行制作人是詹娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。